[Musique]
bonsoir jeudi 18 juin bienvenue dans le
journal de la rédaction de tv 60,18
voici les titres de l'actualité locale
et j - 10 avant le second tour des
élections municipales c'est le 28 juin
prochain sept semaines députés et
sénateurs ont validé les règles
sanitaires pour l'organisation du
scrutin et les dispositions pour les
procurations
que faut-il retenir décryptage après une
chute vertigineuse liés au confinement
le marché de l'automobile semble
rebondir les clients reviennent pour
acheter notamment des véhicules
d'occasion exemple dans une concession à
plaisir et depuis le 6 juin il accueille
à nouveau les riders le stadium de bmx
du vélodrome national de saint quentin
en yvelines a rouvert cyclistes
confirmés et amateurs peuvent retrouver
des sensations tout en respectant les
consignes du gouvernement
quoi qu'il arrive la flamme de la
résistance française ne doit pas
s'éteindre et ne s'éteindra pas c'est
par ces mots que s'est conclue
l'allocution du général de gaulle le 18
juin 1940 sur les ondes de la bbc à
londres
un célèbre appel aux français à
poursuivre le combat alors que la veille
le maréchal pétain annonçait l'armistice
avec l'allemagne nazie
ce jeudi ce sont les 80 ans de ce
célèbre appel du 18 juin de nombreuses
communes des yvelines ont commémoré
aujourd'hui à cette date par le biais de
cérémonie le plus souvent en public à
versailles notamment sur ces images
devant le monument aux morts de la
seconde guerre mondiale le préfet des
yvelines jean jacques brot a lui rendu
hommage à rambouillet cérémonie
également du côté de poissy devant le
buste de charles de gaulle d'autres se
tiennent ce soir comme à guyancourt et
pour les 80 ans de ce célèbre appel
c'est l'occasion de se souvenir de ceux
qui ont résisté pendant la guerre 39 45
est le conseil départemental des
yvelines met à disposition des
ressources pédagogiques en ligne ainsi
qu'un jeu éducatif intitulé réseau conçu
par les archives départementales il
permet de découvrir comment fonctionner
les réseaux clandestins et aussi de
prendre conscience des risques encourus
par les résistants dans l'actualité
aussi le second tour des élections
municipales c'est le
tu es juin prochain à moins de deux
semaines du scrutin députés et sénateurs
ont validé un projet de loi visant à
sécuriser l'organisation de ce second
tour dans quelles conditions va se
dérouler le vote ont fait le point avec
mélanie poker sur saint quentin en
yvelines cette commune invite les
électeurs à se déplacer pour ce second
tour de scrutin le décret voté précise
plusieurs conditions les premières
concerne l'hygiène le bureau de vote
doit prévoir l'accès à un point d'eau et
à du savon ou mettre à disposition du
gel hydroalcoolique
à noter que le masque est rendue
obligatoire pour les électeurs les
membres du bureau de vote les
scrutateurs et toute personne contrôlant
le scrutin un masque qui peut être
retiré à la demande d'un membre du
bureau de vote si le contrôle de
l'identité l exige mais ce masque n'est
pas obligatoire pour les personnes en
situation de handicap
munis d'un certificat médical un
affichage doit être présent à l'entrée
du bureau de vote précisant toutes ces
consignes à une autre mesure spécifique
concerne cette fois les procurations un
mandataire pourra disposer de deux
procurations au lieu d'une
habituellement autorisée par le code
électoral les personnes fragiles malades
ou actuellement en quarantaine peuvent
demander à ce qu'on se déplace chez elle
pour établir ou recevoir le document et
la demande peut aussi être fait par
téléphone courrier ou courriel
il faut alors précisé les raisons qui
empêchent les lecteurs de se déplacer
les procurations pourront être établies
par des officiers ou des agents de
police judiciaire dans des lieux
spécifiques autre que les lieux
habituels qui sont les commissariats et
les gendarmeries les tribunaux la liste
sera elle définit par des arrêtés
préfectoraux et le ministère de
l'intérieur précise qu'une procuration
établie pour le 22 mars est valable pour
le scrutin du 28 juin mais ce n'est pas
le cas pour une procuration réalisé sur
un an et dont la date d'expiration
arrive avant le 28 juin et d'ici le 28
juin tour d'horizon des candidats sont
engagés à villepreux le maire sortant
stéphane mirambeau en lice pour un
troisième mandat fait face à deux autres
listes au premier tour il est arrivé en
troisième position avec ensemble allons
plus loin elle nous lui avons donné deux
minutes pour vous convaincre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je retrouve la force de l'équipe qui
m'avaient accompagné en 2008 ceux qui
sont à mes côtés ne sont pas des
politiques et ne veulent surtout pas
l'être ils ne cherchent pas être député
dans deux ans secrétaire d'état dans
cette conseillère départementale l'année
prochaine et aiment leur ville et
veulent tout simplement s'investir à
cause de cela ils n'ont pas d'ambition
personnelle
au delà de la réussite de leur mandat et
de celle de la commune la force de ma
liste également c'est également mon
expérience de douze années de gestion à
la tête de la ville de vie d'épreuves le
point phare de mon programme est de
savoir justement de quoi je parle
un programme ne doit pas être une suite
de propositions toutes plus belles les
unes que les autres un programme ça doit
expliquer d'où on vient où l'on souhaite
aller pourquoi et comment on le fera
toutes les initiatives de notre
programme sont construites de la même
façon elle se base sur l'histoire de
villepreux sur les projets déjà mené sur
ses perspectives mais également en
prenant en compte les difficultés
budgétaires déjà présentes et celle que
nous allons vivre dans les prochains
mois nous avons bien conscience que
notre programme par rapport à d'autres
fait peut-être moins dribbler et on sait
très bien que le rêve à être toujours
été au coeur de nombreux de mes discours
mais la période qui s'ouvre devant nous
nécessitent très clairement de mettre
comme priorité la réalité
[Applaudissements]
dès mon arrivée je gèlerait l'ensemble
des projets majeurs d'investissement et
en parallèle à l'instar de ce que vous
connaissez le coc des skis au niveau de
saint quentin en yvelines
nous créerons le codho vie de comités de
développement de villepreux il sera
composé des forces vives de la commune
et aura une responsabilité extrêmement
important celles de définir la feuille
de route pour les prochaines années à
guyancourt ils sont également trois à
prétendre au poste de maire dont grégory
pape qui a également deux minutes pour
vous convaincre
à la tête de liste de nouvel élan à
guyancourt a totalisé 18,80 2% des
suffrages le 15 mars dernier
se plaçant en troisième position
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour une équipe municipale c'est avant
tout une famille car on passe des
moments très forts ensemble et je
voulais profiter de ce temps de parole
pour remercier mon équipe
merci bravo c'est vous qui me donne l
énergie de me battre chaque jour pour
défendre nos projets nous avons une
équipe qui est à l'image de guyancourt
c'est à dire riche de par sa diversité
nous venons d'horizons politiques
différents mais nous nous rejoignons
tous sur le même projet qui est de
donner un nouvel élan à guyancourt
[Applaudissements]
nous souhaitons nous aider les uns les
eaux et le bien vivre ensemble alors
s'entre aider les uns les autres c'est
la solidarité
c'est à dire que nous reverrons le
budget du ccas afin de venir en aide aux
plus démunis
nous souhaitons changer de direction en
termes de parcours résidentiel c'est à
dire de favoriser l'accès à la propriété
et ne pas laisser les gens locataires
avis et nous pensons également ou dix
ans courtois et me une part pas en
vacances l'été en leur proposant
aiguille encore plage afin que que de
les enfants les adultes où tout le monde
se retrouve autour d'un dans l'événement
festif l'été pour le vivre ensemble
en fait c'est redonner vie à notre ville
nous allons développer la démocratie
participative notamment via les conseils
de quartier nous allons relocaliser les
habitudes de consommation en faisant la
promotion de nos commerces locaux et
nous allons lutter contre les
incivilités et notamment les rodéos qui
gangrènent la vie des lions courtois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
notre première décision sera de
retravailler en retour à la vie normale
le rôle d'un maire c'est d'être à
l'écouté et d'être agile en cas de
changements tels que nous les avons
vécues récemment
donc nous allons créer une cellule post
crise sanitaire qui va regrouper tous
les acteurs de la ville de guyancourt
que ce soit au niveau économique social
commerce éducation les seniors la
sécurité récente et la famille isolement
social le handicap tout le monde pour
envisager ensemble le jour d'après enfin
un plaisir triangulaire aussi parmi les
candidats l'ex adjoint aux finances
patrick jean ter arrivait deuxième le 15
mars dernier présentation également en
deux minutes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les points forts de la piste c'est avant
tout une liste plaisir oise sans
étiquette avec une majorité de personnes
investies dans le monde citoyens dans le
monde associatif
nous vivons nous aimons notre ville nous
y sommes engagés de longue date et nous
souhaitons effectivement un changement
positif sur différents aspects que ce
soit la santé la solidarité ou
l'écologie et nous sommes tous engagés
sur ce combat commun au delà des trois
aspects effectivement écologie
solidarité santé il en est un qui sort
du lot c'est en particulier la santé
nous souhaitons investir au nom de la
ville sur une maison médicale
pluridisciplinaire de façon à faciliter
la réinstallation durable de médecins
généralistes et de praticiens sur le sol
plaisir oies au nom de la ville avec la
lille et en leur apportant des services
clients leur de façon à ce qu'ils
puissent venir s'installer de manière
durable au service des familles la
première décision c'est surtout d'aller
au contact au contact des agents au
contact des associés sur en contact des
différents partenaires de la ville pour
ensemble bâtir un meilleur dialogue de
confiance aller au contact des quartiers
mais aussi pour mettre en place
rapidement les conseils de quartier et
elle devrait décider ensemble à ce que
va devenir l'avenir de noter en matière
d'écologie de pistes cyclables en
matière de transition énergétique de
santé et surtout de solidarité envers
nos jeunes et nos seniors
[Applaudissements]
et en vue de ce second tour des
élections municipales nous vous
proposons des débats entre les candidats
ce soir à 20 heures
c'est avec les listes engagées à la
verrière c'est à voir sur tv 78 et à
écouter aussi sur les ondes de radio
sensations yvelines fréquence 98 points
4 c'était une condition au bon
déroulement du déconfinement intensifier
les tests au coronavirus aujourd'hui à
la rs et la ville de plaisir organisait
une journée de dépistage au palais des
sports pierre de coubertin
deux sessions étaient proposés aux
professionnels de santé médicaux comme
paramédicaux 200 tests en tout ont été
réservées pour cette action environ 130
personnes étaient attendus sur place et
les propos recueillis par nicolas landry
toute personne peut venir se faire
tester
voilà avec un résultat au bout de dix
minutes donc le principe est simple
c'est une petite piqûre au bout du doigt
on met ensuite un réactif et se réactive
nous disent il ya une immunité
donc c'est un test qu'aux vide il n'y a
pas de fil habilité à 100% il n'y a
aucun test il sera fiable à 100% et
ensuite on pourra savoir c'est une
intéressante ou ancien le virus qui est
de nouveau en légère augmentation dans
les yvelines aux derniers chiffres
publiés hier par la rs 461 patients
étaient hospitalisés sur le territoire
soit deux ans plus en 24 heures 25 était
encore en réanimation
entre mardi et mercredi un décès
supplémentaire a été recensé à l'hôpital
portant le nombre total de victimes à
511 depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire 2037 personnes ont été guéries
de lakovic 19
après un passage à l'hôpital le
coronavirus qui a entraîné vous le savez
le confinement et puis le déconfinement
qui s'est enclenchée depuis le 11 mai
avec parfois aidé retour à l'école ou au
travail entre jours de classe en
présentiel à la maison télétravail est
difficile de s'organiser pour les
familles marylène iapichino a justement
rencontré une famille de saint germain
de la grange pour qui c'est souvent la
course en ce moment regarder dans cette
famille recomposée et des confiné i lya
mathilde est clément les enfants de
sandrine qui vont à l'école primaire et
maternelle de saint germain de la grange
et lucas et nolan les enfants de laurent
qui vont à l'école primaire de plaisir
et au collège de ben une semaine sur
deux la famille passe de 2 à 6
et pour gérer le déconfinement avec des
jours d'école différents selon les
enfants il faut de l'organisation comme
si chez ma mère puisque je suis
prioritaire et mais je vais à l'école
toute la semaine de quatre jours et
quand chez mon père en fait comme il
n'est pas prioritaire je vais une seule
fois par semaine et en plus des trajets
différents pour les amener à l'école il
faut gérer les repas clément
tu goûtes aussi donnant tu vas au centre
le soir tu vas la garderie nous tord à
deux ça y'a pas de cantine et on peut
pas réchauffer les plats donc en fait
ces repas froid donc le plus simple
effectivement c'est les sandwichs
difficulté supplémentaire laurent
entamer un nouveau travail
juste avant le confinement il a dû céder
confiné plus tôt dès le 25 avril et
reprendre un rythme complet de 39 heures
petit appétit repart de plus belle dans
l'organisation et puis c'est vrai que en
tant donné que je ne peux pas emmener
les enfants l'art l'heure actuelle est
que ma femme les gardent à l'esprit peut
se permettre de se mettre en tas des
treuils les jours où les enfants n'ont
pas école sandrine et donc en
télétravail depuis le confinement à la
pris ses habitudes
les enfants font leurs devoirs le matin
et joue l'après midi j'essaye de faire
mon maximum
un peu comme général se fiche pas de
bruit ou quand je leur dis quand mon
téléphone sonne voilà de pas faire trop
de bruit à côté alors forcément
l'annoncé de la reprise de l'école de 22
juin était un soulagement même si tout
le monde s'est bien adapté à ce rythme
un peu chamboulé et un peu ils sont tes
jouets a charmé plus d'un mètre en vain
c'est juste assez solidaire sur
certaines fois et puis bien sûr
chamailleries passage ça restait la
fratrie pour le coup donc voilà je pense
qu'il n'y a pas vraiment pour nous tous
les six partiront en vacances au camping
en france pour se reposer de tout ça et
profiter d'être ensemble en espérant une
rentrée en septembre plus sereine avant
de s'attaquer à un nouveau projet
nécessitant organisation le mariage de
sandrine et laurent prévu initialement
en mai dernier est repoussée à l'année
prochaine
un mode économie avec ce chiffre
édifiant au mois d'avril le nombre de
véhicules vendus a chuté de 88% en
france m et depuis le marché semble
rebondir les établissements ouverts et
les clients reviennent peu à peu pour
acheter des véhicules d'occasion
notamment exemple à plaisir dans une
concession avec nicolas landry un
véritable rebond d'activité dans cette
concession automobile des appels des
contacts par internet
l'activité a repris le 11 mai dans cet
établissement fermé pendant le
confinement
les clients sont vite revenus on a fait
sur quinze jours l'équivalent d'un mois
de
de commerce sur le mois de mai ça a été
ça a été assez fulgurant impressionnant
s'est même retrouvé avec un des clients
plusieurs clients sur la même voiture
on a eu un pic d'activité qui est de 30%
supérieur à ce qu'on a sur un mois de
mai habituels les véhicules d'occasion
ont eu le plus de succès dans cette
reprise le plan de relance du secteur
automobile annoncé par le président de
la république
un site à l'acquisition de véhicules
vers une aide de 7000 euros pour l'achat
d'un véhicule électrique et une prime de
2000 euros pour l'achat d'un véhicule
hybride où on a eu beaucoup beaucoup de
demandes par téléphone suite à cela
savoir si nos véhicules et éligibles
quels véhicules on pouvait proposer par
rapport à cela donc ça se prêtait très
bien avec l'actualité mini et bmw avec
la mini électrique ou des véhicules plus
récents comme le x3 hybride 6 1 re
démarrage est constatée dans cette
concession une reprise durable est
espéré sur les deux mois de confinement
l'établissement a perdu près de 80% de
son chiffre d'affaires ce dimanche c'est
la fête de la musique un événement
forcément en particulier en ce contexte
de crise sanitaire et qui ne pourra se
tenir dans des conditions normales
plusieurs communes ont décidé d'ailleurs
d'annuler les festivités pour se
conformer aux gestes barrières certaines
ont tout de même décidé de maintenir des
animations avec le respect de la
distanciation physique à maurepas vous
donne rendez vous à partir de 16h dans
les commerces de la ville pour des
concerts à magny les hameaux
c'est une déambulation musicale qui vous
est proposé à 15h30 entre le musée et la
granja blé fête de la musique au balcon
et au jardin à plaisir laissez libre
cours à votre créativité musicale depuis
chez vous pour figurer dans la
programmation rapprochez vous de la
direction des affaires culturelles
enfin versailles et coignières par
exemple ont choisi de diffuser des
concerts en live sur leur page facebook
pour refermer ce journal depuis le 6
juin il a retrouvé ses pratiquants c'est
le stadium de bmx du vélodrome national
de saint quentin en yvelines par petits
groupes les riders s'entraîne à nouveau
il est ouvert ce stadium aux cyclistes
confirmés comme amateur mais les
horaires ont néanmoins été réaménagé les
habitudes changent et pour respecter les
consignes sanitaires mélanie poké et
mathilde et demi ils ont retrouvé les
sensations de la ride en reprenant le
chemin des pistes pour les entraînements
de bmx au stadium de st quentin en
yvelines et cyclistes sont ravis de
pouvoir à nouveau pédaler après deux
mois d'arrêt ça fait du bien rester long
confinement nous prêts à ça fait du bien
de pouvoir pour faire du sport à travers
plaisir quand même quelques
investigations
on peut - on est moins nombreux un petit
groupe de 10 et ouais c'est par
intervalles on peut pas il ya eu tous
les jours comme on voulait avant même si
l'engouement est total pour les riders
la reprise se fait dans un premier temps
en douceur les compétitions qui ont été
reportés reprendront en septembre avec
des coupes d'europe et championnat de
france aujourd'hui vailli il travaille
beaucoup les départs et la première
ligne droite après aussi des courses
kinoïde qui ont été reportés en bave à
partir de septembre jusqu'à on va dire
décembre on aboutit à des courses qui
sont qui vont devenir donc oui je pense
il travaille va retravailler
l'accélération se remettre dedans
gentiment pour respecter les règles
sanitaires le stadium a réduit le nombre
de cyclistes sur les pistes passant de
50 riders à seulement 10 des
professionnels aux débutants tout le
monde peut quand même s'exercer en
respectant la distanciation physique on
a différentes consignes différents
protocoles qu'on doit appliquer de
manière stricte c'est aussi notre
volonté on a évidemment l'ambition de
rouvrir nos activités indoor
maintenant il faut savoir qu'on n'a plus
tôt l'ambition de favoriser nos
pratiques outdoor autour du vélo mais on
en parle mais on en parle on essaye de
mettre tout ce qu'on peut mettre en
oeuvre pour rouvrir l'intérieur du
vélodrome
des baptêmes de bmx sont proposées tous
les samedis pour l'instant l'équipe du
vélodrome favorise l'extérieur en
attendant que l'intérieur ne rouvre la
date du 22 juin est en partie révoquée
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité très belle soirée à tous
sur tv 78
[Musique]